secretary of state anthony blinken made
a last-minute detour to the united
nations on his way to europe to address
the security council again warning that
russia was poised to attack ukraine
some have called into question our
information
recalling previous instances where
intelligence ultimately did not bear out
but let me be clear
i am here today
not to start a war
but to prevent one russia's deputy
foreign minister sergey vershinin called
the accusations baseless insisting that
weapons supplied to ukraine by the west
are the real threat
the fact is that the russian forces were
on the russian territory and remain on
russian territory and the day before
yesterday some of the units after their
exercises were returning to their home
bases
still many countries expressed concern
as the number of russian troops on the
border appears to be increasing
and while russia presented its own
evidence of alleged ukrainian war crimes
against separatists the u.s and others
dismissed the claims as a false pretext
to invade these are fake and
irresponsible allegations by russia
aimed at hiding its responsibility for
the occupation of the ukrainian
territories and subsequent human rights
violations there excellencies ukraine
remains committed to peaceful resolution
the one thing security council members
appear to agree on is that the 2015
minsk agreement which was signed to end
conflict in eastern ukraine be the basis
of defusing tensions but as thursday's
meeting made clear
russia and ukraine have very different
views on how that deal should be
implemented
kristen salooni al-jazeera the united
nations